bella di ragazzi benvenuti questo video
sono valigie io oggi voglio fare una
cosa molto conoscete l'impossible
game the impossible game sarebbe il
predecessore di questo gioco che conosce
anche mia nonna
se riuscisse a tirare su tutto gli
skinny sarebbe meglio questo gioco
chiamato geometri dash che veramente ci
ha giocato chiunque anche lo posso un
morto nelle fogne di casa vostra questo
gioco prima di diventare così era in
versione molto più easy molto meno
drogata e sia vate impossibili game
gioco che io l'ho fatto un sacco di
volte nella mia vita anche sul canale
quindi lo so fare durante il video
ho voluto provare a fare una cosa un po
strana ho voluto provare a giocare solo
con la bocca non avete idea di quello
che state per vedere ragazzi ve lo giuro
buona visione ai ragazzi nei fossi io il
game è questo che state per vedere
livello 1 non mi ricordo niente ma mi
ricordo che riuscivo a finirlo in un
tentativo solo è passato tanto tempo
vediamo se sono diventato stupido se la
risposta è sì ok concentrato
se riesco a fare il primo livello a me
l'uccello non volevo dire questo però
trovavano arriva solo con uccello weiler
gol alla ragazzi porco il demonio di
incastrato nei muri dove conoscente vo
dao militare questo pigiama mi serve per
meditare ragazzi quindi tranquilli cielo
allora volevo dire è impossibile game
per chi non lo conoscesse ripeto è un
giorno e ti piace molto più tranquillo
vedete però è tutto nato da questo
perché geometria speciale ha copiato
spudoratamente ed è veramente figo
perché a me piaceva tantissimo era
bellissimo e ci giochiamo sul mio primo
ipod touch che molti voi giovani non
sanno manco cos'è poiché era povero non
si poteva permettere l'iphone e l'ipod
touch che era un iphone che non chiamava
che quindi il costava di meno ci lega vi
dietro il tuo telefono nokia schifoso
così diventavano iphone e io ce l'avevo
su quel ipod touch i agosto gioco qua mi
ero allenato un sacco sul retro della
macchina dei miei genitori quando mi
accompagnavano a scuola perché io devo
sta roba qua è infatti si è visto come
sono cresciuto tutto storto e sto
facendo io faccio il discorso stupido
nel mentre sto riuscendo a fare il
livello incredibile
me lo ricordo neanche ragazzi è passata
una vita non è stupido maledetto pietro
va bene dai ci riproviamo ragazzo non
carico sono carico a molla
mi sa che vi faccio vedere il mouse
perché se non sembra che clicco io
l'ultima volta qualcuno si era lamentata
ma non clicchi totò cliccando io e
realtà vi faccio vedere anzi col naso lo
faccio col naso ci provo ragazzi livello
col naso e difficile e molto difficile
col naso aspetta
la ragazza non fenomeno norme detto il
mio naso e poco reattivo ragazzi devo
provare a farlo in un modo con la bocca
ma voglio farlo in modo strano parco
demoni è difficilissimo
maledizione ragazzi devo riuscire ci
devo riuscire ce la faccio
ce la faccia tipo farlo con un qualcosa
che non è il dito con la bocca devo
riuscirci giuro visto concentra ce la
farò me lo sento
[Musica]
maledizione decidesse un ora posso fare
se è veramente difficile l'unico
problema è che se lo faccio con la bocca
manca al commenta rinaldi prefiggo sono
riuscito a fare un bel pezzo
non è vero non è non è facile perché il
tempo di l'azione della masticazione più
lento vi assicuro che non è facile
alexa mettimi la canzone motivazionale
playlist di musica motivazionale damaso
music amici ma quando già vicino e alexa
alexa.com sta vicina che stai a dì dai
basta che c'è il copyright alexa stop ci
trovo posso anche ragazzi farmi sbattere
il muso in faccia volendo non è male
come cosa ha un effetto massaggiante
tutto questo
ok preside o cos'è cos'è cos'è accaduto
qua cosa è successo ragazzi non pensavo
di fare così tanto casino ok che chrome
è accaduta come ho fatto a rompere il
gioco ho dato una botta talmente forte
la mia faccia che si è rotto il gioco
ragazzi sta parte non ha segreti st
parte non ha segreti
sono un fenomeno guardalo come si
destreggia bene mamma mia ragazzi anni
di youtube per questo per tirarmi le ma
usate in faccia da solo
manco pietro né stati l'ammanco pietro
io mi ritiro
guardalo maledizione ero più però anche
la bocca devo finirlo in un modo strano
ragazzo che con la bocca se lo tengono
riesco a parlare non è scappare
commentari pro lei era troppo bello c
dove di provare scusatemi
ok
aiuto
[Musica]
maledizione maledizione difficilissimo
procedevo riuscire laga è una questione
di vita o di morte dai
[Musica]
aiuto
a
[Musica]
ho io
olio
[Musica]
[Applauso]
questo è il mio nonno usate codice frigi
tv per di supporto che grazie ragazzi
mamma mia che giocata collaborerà in
crisi e che non ci avrei scommesso un
euro su me stesso incredibile non so se
il codice supporto del falso effetto
però può essere usate lo incredibile non
pensarci sì veramente con la bocca in
credo che mai nessuno può dire niente di
giocava un altro no perché si vede
esattamente quando salto il ghiaccio
bellissimo ecco questo era è un po
kringe da vedere però nè nella mia vita
tutto questo ha senso solo nella mia
vita però va beh chi se ne frega
ragazzi ho finalmente una roba fatta
finalmente un video merita e meritevole
bello pensavate fosse click day che
invece non sono soddisfatto adesso
faccio anche il cubo di rubik perché
devono dimostrare di essere skillato ha
troppe skill oggi troppe scrive ragazzi
iscrivetevi al canale ma l'inizio però è
che gli sia piaciuto ragazzi con il
covino indotto una descrizione se non
sei da per discrete ma come sempre ci
vediamo da ragazzo
[Musica]